[Musique]
alors avec votre permission
nous avons fait un petit exercice et
j'ai préféré le plaisir de vos
entretenir la presse la levée simplement
les mains si vous avez eu à participer à
une réunion du conseil municipal de
votre commune
une personne
lever les mains si vous avez eu adressé
une correspondance à l'autorité de votre
quartier de votre arrondissement de
votre ville par rapport à un problème
que vous avez constaté et je donne
l'exemple d'un trou dans la rue de
lampadaires il ne fonctionne pas
je trouve
personne depuis l'accession à
l'indépendance dans les années 60 les
pays africains continuent de chercher la
meilleure stratégie haut
le développement de leur nation de la
paix
développement sans parler de politique
publique ou simplement des mesures des
solutions des plans ils sont conçus pour
résoudre les problèmes qui affectent la
communauté le public en général
ce le continent noir
la prérogative d'élaborer les politiques
publiques a souvent été laissé aux
gouvernants le citoyen où les citoyens
vous et moi avions développé l'habitude
d'attendre que la solution soit trouvée
et de nous prononcer
prenons un instant pour réfléchir
qu'aurait été le développement si chaque
citoyen se refuser le devoir de
s'impliquer
serait la gestion de la ville si les
citoyens de la ville de manière
proactive décide de sensibiliser
d'interpublic d'informer les autorités
de la ville par rapport aux problèmes
qui se passe autour
que serait la salubrité
si des jeunes dans une rue décide de
s'impliquer en se mettant ensemble pour
balayer au lieu d'attendre que la mairie
envoie le personnel
l'implication des citoyens dans
l'élaboration des politiques publiques
est unique pour les matic qu'il devait
nous concerner tous
réussite individuelle n'est pas
dissociable la réussite collective
lorsque je réussis mais tout autour de
moi c'est la souffrance serait en mesure
de jouir de ma réussite chèrement
acquise par le fruit de mes efforts
si je souhaite je vous
ire des fruits de mes efforts il urge
est non seulement je me batte pour moi
même et ma famille mais que je
m'implique dans ce que ma communauté
denière et c'est ce qui m'a motivé
ancien banquier de formation et de
profession a décidé d'aller dans le
développement et avait spécialisé
désormais dans les politiques publiques
je me suis amusé cette année a fait un
travail de recherche
ils ont étudié comment les citoyens
béninois s'implique dans la politique
publique parce que lorsqu'on parle de
politique publique démystifiant cela
ensemble ou ce que cela veut dire
ce sont des solutions des mesures des
plans programmes pour résoudre les
problèmes publics c'est-à-dire des
problèmes qui affectent le grand nombre
un petit cours de politique publique
mais si je veux juste rappeler le cycle
ce que l'on identifie le problème nous
les citoyens et nos autorités
et après avoir vu le problème il
faudrait formuler les solutions dont la
formulation de la politique publique et
après la formulation il faudrait trouver
ou adopter une stratégie parmi les
nombreuses les écouter donc l'exécution
des politiques publiques et après
l'évaluer mais lorsque je pense chaque
étape de ce cycle
je viens de décrire ou est-ce que vous
et moi à quel instant ou à quel moment
nous intervenons j'ai posé un mental de
mes propos la question de savoir qui a
participé à la réunion du conseil
municipal de sa commune
une personne a levé clé mais cela veut
dire que lorsque le conseil municipal se
réunit pour élaborer les stratégies et
les solutions pour résoudre les
problèmes de la communauté à laquelle
vous et moi nous appartenons nous les
laissons faire et nous subissons et
après nous parlons pour ne pas dire nous
bavardons
la réalité est que nous vivons dans des
pays où nous avons le droit et la
possibilité d'intervenir mais peut-être
parce que nous n'avions pas grandi avec
la culture de nous impliquer
volontairement dans la résolution des
problèmes qui affectent notre communauté
nous laissons faire
le résultat de mes recherches cette
année est là
je voulais dire porter sur la
participation citoyenne dans
l'élaboration des politiques publiques
nous avons questionné 900 jeunes dans
les douze départements du bénin
et figurez-vous que seulement 40%
on prépare d'une manière ou d'une autre
à l'élaboration d'une politique publique
le mieux nous avions pris le cas
spécifique de la politique nationale de
la jeunesse puisque nous étions allés
vers les jeunes
et le constat était que cet instrument
dans le bénin s'est dotée
béninoise y subir à l'application donc
des mesures de 7 pour les tic tout au
moins pour l'échantillon espionner
à 80% les jeunes ne savaient même pas
qu'un tel document existe
l'afrique se développe la tête le bénin
dans les 50 prochaines années
ce développeur at-il à plus de 52 % ça
populace à plus de 62% sa population est
jeune et plus de 50 2% sa population
féminine
le sort du bénin est dans la main de sa
jeunesse et de sa fille
or sera réglé si vous et moi décidions
de nous impliquer
10 je me suis porté volontairement
prophète d'un message
je désire toute la population aussi bien
au bénin en afrique à cet adepte et vie
la décision de s'impliquer dans la
gestion de la communauté
cela n'a rien de politique l'art de
diriger la cité il s'agit tout
simplement du développement de notre
communauté et de la jouissance de la
réussite individuelle derrière laquelle
chacun de nos pour désormais dans le
quartier prenons la peine de nous
impliquer
avec cette petite anecdote
justin au début de ce mois
mon épouse et moi avions envoyé un
courrier ou délégué du quartier haut
commissaire au chef d'arrondissement au
maire et au préfet pour leur dire nous
voulons rassembler les jeunes dans un
creuset parce que nous avons accès à
beaucoup d'opportunités et nous
souhaitons partager cette opportunité
avec les jeunes afin qu après l an leur
niveau puissent passer d'ici à là cela
requiert pour nous de sacrifier nos ça
veut dire tous les deux amis d'hier du
mort cela requiert pour nous d'activer
nos réseaux d'amis pour être des
formateurs mais nous avions compris que
c'est à ce seul prix que nous puisons
nous pouvons jouir de la réussite
personnelle familiale en voyant tout
autour de nous des familles qui
deviennent meilleurs parce que la
jeunesse et autonomiser
monsieur comprenons ce soir que la
réussite individuelle n'est pas
dissociable la réussite collective
comprenons ce soir que le citoyen qui ne
s'impliquent pas peut parler à longueur
de journée de développement mais c'est
par abbas en sortant de cette salle
agissons un coup de fil une lettre à
rédiger
sion et soyons des artisans du
changement une souhaitons voir
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]